[Música]
bueno pues hoy tengo el gusto de poder
platicar con ustedes una experiencia y
un proyecto del que formado parte y
hacerlo aquí en mi ciudad en mi casa
pues es un gusto y un privilegio yo
platicarles de esta experiencia que
empezó cuando hay un muy chico lo
recuerdo muy bien que de niño mis papás
nos llevaban a la playa aquí en coche a
cuartos y no me gustaba ahí la razón por
la que no nos gustaba ir es porque
regreso las chanclas y nos traía el
llenado de chapopote las tenía que
limpiar yo no entendía en ese momento
que era lo que pasaba pero me di cuenta
que mi primer contacto con el medio
ambiente fue a través de este evento de
contaminación
de ahí por cuestiones de trabajo a mi
padre lo cambian a la ciudad de méxico
me voy para allá tengo mi segundo
encuentro y el segundo entendimiento de
lo que es el medio ambiente cultiva
ayora jugar fútbol algo que nos apasiona
atrás todos los mexicanos y no pudiera
jugar porque había w hoy no circula
entonces se cancelaban todas las
actividades algo que no entendía yo que
era lo que pasaba y por qué no podía yo
realizar una actividad que hacía normal
de ahí fui metiéndome al tema ambiental
fui conociendo iniciativas y me dio
mucho gusto cuando en méxico salió por
ley como abogado no puedo dejar de estar
pendiente estas cosas y sale por ley el
que tenemos que empezar a separar en
orgánico o inorgánico y yo sentía que
íbamos por buen camino que estábamos
avanzando que era la manera en la que
íbamos a hacer las cosas y por
oportunidades académicas tuve la
oportunidad de irme a estudiar a londres
mientras estaba allá y yo quería
presumir lo que hacíamos en nuestro país
por fin ir separando los residuos o
llegó y me topo con que ellos ya van en
cuatro votos y entonces si se me estaba
complicando tener dos votos en la casa
para orgánico e inorgánico
pues aquí ya había orgánico ya había en
orgánico había papel cartón había
aluminio y había peso y de ahí tuve la
oportunidad de participar en dos expos
internacionales una en aichí japón y
otra en zaragoza españa y cuando yo que
japón de los cuatro botes pasé a siete y
entonces os decir oye no hay manera de
poder tener siete votos porque estos
siete votos los tengo que tener pues
también en casa y no hay va a haber
forma de que yo convenza y mamá de que
pueda tener 27 votos diferentes de
basura en la casa y me llamó mucho la
atención quién que es en japón pues la
gente realmente lo hacía con convicción
mientras nosotros estábamos en la expo
si alguien veía algo tirado en la calle
simplemente se agachaba lo recogía y lo
ponía en donde iba no había problema el
mundo de ahí soy un enamorado de mi
ciudad hace 10 años tomé la decisión de
regresar mi vida en cuarta cuarto y con
o como no podíamos encontrar la
respuesta desde la iniciativa privada
todo mundo me decía es que estos
problemas son grandes a una gran escala
y sólo pueden ser desde gobierno y tome
la decisión de la eterna trabajar en el
gobierno y cuando yo estaba trabajando
en un gobierno primero el tema del agua
y estando en el tema del agua iba a dar
pláticas a las escuelas sobre la
concientización ambiental y tratando de
cambiar el gobierno y me acuerdo mucho
punto ayer un jardín de niños chiquitos
y ese jardín era el que más agua
consumida de todas las escuelas que lo
fui a ver ahora y entonces los niños en
el recreo jugaban a quien podía hacer
sobre el tubo de cobre quien podía hacer
que saliera el rollo más grande de auto
la venta de monedas de 5 pesos la
ventaja en monedas de 10 pesos y ganaba
el que creara la fuga de agua nacional y
tú le preguntamos al profesor y por qué
dejas que los niños por esa sentencia
pues el agua es gratis no la paga mucho
y así con vuestra experiencia me punto
cuando compare en varios lados y fui en
alguna ocasión tuve la oportunidad de
platicar con otra escuela los
convencimos de ir separando los residuos
empezamos a separar el material y ya que
lo tenía todo separado pues nos topamos
con otro problema que fue y ahora qué
hacemos con lo que se para y no había
nadie que pasará por ese material
separado y es realmente frustrante y lo
entiendo perfecto cuando tú haces esta
separación en casa y pasan a recogerla y
se lleva todo junto y de ahí pues como
nos pasan muchos iniciamos algún
proyecto me topé compañero de disolución
y aún poco tuve casi un año y medio sin
seguir haciendo actividades
medioambientales y tuve la oportunidad
de ir a cenar un día a casa de un amigo
y me di cuenta cuando iba yo entrando
pues que también tenía ir separado del
pd había una pila de libros ahí vas
limitándola y no es como pasas y le
preguntas a hoy y qué haces tú con lo
que separan y me dice nada ya lo separó
pasa el camión lo vuelve a juntar todo
pero yo no quiero dejar de separarlo
porque quiero que mis hijos tengan esa
formación
y entonces uno ahí toma decisiones y se
da cuenta que la solución a los
problemas que tenemos nosotros no
depende de la iniciativa privada no
depende del gobierno no depende de lo
que es conocido como el sector social
porque al final de cuentas depende de
todos el gobierno no es un ente
extraordinario formado de diferentes
personas somos nosotros mismos que
tenemos oportunidad de realizar un
servicio público y la solución a los
problemas tiene que ser entenderlo eso
ese ha sido uno de los grandes retos a
los que nos topamos porque cuando
iniciamos este proyecto hace cuatro años
hicimos iniciarlo en una expoferia aquí
en juárez a cuantos leímos los libros
internacionales los códigos de colores y
ahí fuimos pintamos los tambos de 200
litros de rojo el de estos de azul el de
estos de amarillo a que le pusimos un
letrero que decía cartón papel aluminio
y la gente fue caminando
tiraba la basura no se daba cuenta que
tenía que separarlos porque tuvimos toda
una generación completa que creció con
el único esquema ambiental que había
antes que era deposita la basura en su
lugar y eso nos enseñaron a hacer
eso fuimos aprendiendo fue lo que nos
fueron repitiendo y nos dimos cuenta que
el principal problema que teníamos era
que no sabíamos que tenemos un problema
no podemos resolver los problemas que
tenemos si no aceptamos que lo tenemos
cuando hemos tenido la oportunidad de
platicar en las escuelas no hemos tenido
la oportunidad de platicar en las
empresas sobre esta situación
tú le preguntas cuál es el problema de
la basura y si el problema de la basura
es que no pasa el camión a llevársela
cuando está por annika y entonces
estamos tratando de resolver el problema
de la basura al final y no desde el
principio el problema que tenemos es que
no conocemos que tenemos un problema
nadie sabe a dónde se van sus vecinos
nueve de cada diez personas a las que
tenemos oportunidad de platicar no sabe
nada no se han sometido solamente saben
que cuando la sacan eventualmente se van
y cuando tú empiezas a explicar las
consecuencias que tiene esa base eso que
compramos eso que tiramos que eso que
desperdiciamos empiezas a entenderlo y
empiezas a hacerlo por voluntad
ese es al final del día una de las cosas
que nosotros hemos identificado no va a
haber manera de que podamos solucionar
los problemas que tenemos si no le
explicamos a la gente cuáles son las
consecuencias de los actos que realizan
porque una vez que lo hemos hecho una
vez que lo haya entendido nosotros al
día de hoy tenemos cerca de 200
contenedores a lo largo de toda la
ciudad tenemos un modelo de contenedor
diferente transparente que permite ver
qué hay adentro y la gente ha entendido
que es para colocar otro tipo de
residuos es para facilitarle la
separación de los vecinos y se ha vuelto
consciente nosotros llegamos a reciclar
cerca de 15 toneladas antes de la
pandemia y con la pandemia llegó un
momento donde pues si estábamos en la
decisión de si cerrado no solo porque la
mayoría de nuestros proyectos eran en
escuelas y afortunadamente de una manera
ahora sí que nos hizo muy feliz la gente
que había iniciado estos proyectos en la
escuela como no había clases por la
pandemia dijo ya traen un contenedor a
mi casa ya me puse de acuerdo con mis
vecinos vamos a empezar a separarlos acá
y entonces eso te permite darte cuenta
de una cosa que es muy importante cada
iniciativa cada idea cada cosa que te
apasiona y te motiva no estamos solos en
ellos hay mucha gente que comparte
nuestro entusiasmo y que está esperando
que alguien inicie este movimiento
inició una idea para poder llevarla a
cabo entonces cada que nosotros tengamos
algo que queremos resolver debemos de
recordar que no estamos solos en la
solución de ese problema hoy nosotros
seguimos activos seguimos reciclando
cerca de 5 toneladas que vienen
directamente de nuestras casas ya no hay
que preocuparse qué vamos a hacer cuando
ese material llegue al éxito de
discusión final porque estamos
resolviendo tratando reforma del
problema desde el principio y no lo
estamos haciendo porque llegué yo
gobierno y le diga cada vez ustedes lo
tienen que hacer lo estamos haciendo
porque la gente está convencida de que
es algo que tiene que hacer por eso
nosotros en este proyecto le estamos
apostando a la educación ambiental
tenemos que ser capaces de explicarle a
cada uno de nosotros por qué debemos de
cuidarnos
medio ambiente qué consecuencias tiene
porque al final del día esa es la mejor
manera de poder resolver los problemas
que nosotros como ciudadanos nos
entendamos que no lo hagamos porque hay
una ley que nos lo dice que no lo
hagamos porque me pueden venir a
sancionar que lo hagamos porque estamos
convencidos de que esas acciones que
tenemos que tomar son las que en
realidad van a cuidar a nuestro medio
ambiente y de esta forma hemos logrado
ir creciendo empezamos con un municipio
y ahí nos fuimos expandiendo otros
municipios de la región seguimos
trabajando con ellos entonces esta es la
reflexión la experiencia y limitación
que yo quiero compartir con ustedes uno
tenemos que reconocer que tenemos un
problema existe la primera fase de poder
solucionarlo nos hemos dedicado
prácticamente a negar la existencia de
que tenemos un problema tenemos un
problema de tratamiento de agua tenemos
un problema de manejo de basura tenemos
un problema de consumismo es una
realidad pero si no lo queremos aceptar
no pasa nada para que nos apareciera
es malo reconocer que tenemos un
problema todos nosotros tenemos
problemas día a día que tenemos que
resolver no pasa nada cuando lo
reconocemos porque si no terminamos
aplicando soluciones de recuerdo antes
de venirme al corte juego de una plática
con la conagua y nos decía oye la cuenca
del río corte cual es la segunda más
contaminada del país pero ya los últimos
no se pone contento cuando escuchas ya
lo solucionamos en productos que hiciste
ya la limpiamos y con eso lo
solucionamos y preguntas porque es la
cuenca más contaminada del país y es que
no hay planta de tratamiento y sale el
agua directo pero ya lo limpiando y no
puede uno estar producto al fuelle y no
sigue saliendo del agua directo esa
labor es un baldón directo sí y no se va
a volver a contaminar sí pues entonces
realmente esa no fue la solución al
problema una solución temporal porque no
lo atacamos desde el origen y lo
atacamos al final entonces primero
aceptemos que tenemos problemas no pasa
nada
con aceptarlo para empezar a solucionar
lo segundo
ya no decía la educación es la mejor
manera de cambiar al mundo
y ese es el reto que tenemos que hacer
que la gente haga este cambio porque
realmente lo quiere hacer porque está
convencida de que lo necesitamos y no
que sea golpe de ley o no que sea golpe
de sanción no va a haber manera que como
sociedad no podemos si lo seguimos
intentando así hasta este momento no nos
ha funcionado
y entonces al final del día debemos de
recordar que una ciudad no es limpia
porque se barra mucho una ciudad es
limpia porque se ensucia por gracia
[Aplausos]